feel good hello and welcome to the feels
good
podcast please welcome this amazingly
talented athlete and all around
great person mr juju smith schuster yeah
that's pretty cool
i'm from i was born in pittsburgh my
like my grandparents are from there my
mom and dad were in college there like
we were
my sisters and i were all born there but
then i moved to connecticut for like
nine years and then to florida so
but my dad has steelers all over his
house like
he has a signed football i got from him
for him before he just like watches the
games every sunday
he's like you're interviewing juju oh my
god
that's so funny i asked when i came to
pittsburgh i was like 20 years old and i
came to like you know coming from los
angeles i came to a small like a
small city and they die hard
love sports here so i didn't drive i i
can have my license sometimes so i lived
in south side like
i don't know if you there's a cheesecake
packaging south side and
it's it's an awesome city i love it here
and the fans are amazing
uh it's so funny here from pittsburgh
that's like out of all the places in the
world like
you know being who you are coming from a
city like this like people probably
never know
yeah well it's like you know i tried to
visit when i can now like
my whole family kind of are snowbirds
and they moved down
south so i have like one grandma left in
pittsburgh
so i still try oh actually no my aunt is
there too oh she's gonna hate me for
that i don't know if that makes me
bandwagon
what what defines bandwagon it's like
you're not watching every game but
you're still supporting the team
yeah a bandwagon is someone like right
now you know we're 11
and one so it's like wow i'm ready for
the best team but then again like
you have that hometown advantage like i
got the room pittsburgh so you got the
roof so it's
really not that way okay good thank you
for that i'm sure all the comments are
going to be like nah your bandwagon
um but i appreciate it and i do have the
roots so it's fine
but so you're originally from l.a yes i
was
born in long beach california i went to
long beach went to
uh usc for two and two and a half years
and then
decided to live my dream and growing up
you always played football
like you're how did you get into it so
i've been playing football since i was
like
four years old and i also played i also
played rugby
uh because of my mom she's simone so i
was always
in that rugby was like a big traditional
for polynesians
so i did that i'll turn on track i hated
track but you know something
you got to do during the off season as a
football player um
and then you know stuck with it ever
since i i
knew i could get a scholarship for it to
go to college
and i did that and it kind of just paid
out now i'm in my fourth year into the
nfl
it's so awesome my god like how crazy is
that you
did you when you started were you like
so confident of
yeah i'm gonna be in the nfl it's
happening i'm not worried about it
that's that's just what i'm doing yeah
so like everyone talks about an it
factor
and the effect for me was i would say
like my freshman year in college
my freshman year in high school um i go
into the office
and just this lady named coach kim's
like hey what college you want to go to
and she literally can name every college
you
probably get to go from d1 to d2 to d3
and i was like i want to go to ufc
so that uh fast forward a year later you
know i started i got a call from san
jose state
i got a call from oregon got a call from
like
literally all these schools and at that
point i was like oh yeah
i think i want to be playing nfl because
and i had like 35 offers to go to
college
for scholarships and i was like geez usc
it is i'm staying home
i was just trying to get in one i was
like all right who's gonna
who's gonna take me but i ended up going
down
for the state music yeah
it was such a party school so much fun
and it but like the games were so much
fun too
like you guys were good back then too
uh-huh
it was like bandwagon then too because i
would go and i'd party at the games and
i just go because it was just so much
fun and the energy was so much fun
but i went to ucf for a year before
florida state
and like it was more of like um
it was fun but i like wanted the
traditional
college experience and i always just
loved florida state so i was like all
right i was like a little bit because
i'm from
like west palm beach um this area called
stuart florida
and then i was like all right i don't
want to go too far because i still like
i was working like three jobs in college
so i was like i'm just gonna stay kind
of close to home so every weekend
i had a really good bartending job and i
made a lot of money bartending so i'm
like every other weekend i'll just come
down so i'll do ucf this year
and then next year do fsu so that's kind
of how i made
my decision so how did you how did you
like
to where you're at today what made you
like when was your factor
about me i'm asking you to be like wow
this is what i want to do with like for
my life for a living
i think i've always kind of just did
what i
wanted in the moment and
but i think i don't know actually being
spontaneous
and seeing opportunities i think is kind
of what led me
out to la and being where i i am now
and you know taking risks but also
i would say vine vine is what really
like blew me up
like being on that platform and then
me just putting out content that i shot
and
edited and just like threw out there
didn't thinking anything of it i'm just
like i'm learning how to use this
platform
and then seeing millions of people or
thousands of people at the time the
millions of people
starting to support it and watch it i'm
like this
is something you know it's like the same
with you when the colleges were all
reaching out to you and you're like oh
there's something yeah i got this i need
something that's working
yeah i mean and you're no you like
especially are no stranger to social
media you have
3.4 million instagram followers
1.1 million twitter followers 1.1
million youtube subscribers and 2.5
million followers on tick tock like how
do you find the time
as a professional athlete to do social
media
it's it's so hard um it's hard and easy
it goes both ways
i would say this in college i was inside
social media people were like my best
friend
was like yo you should get social media
i'm like nah i think it's bad you know
every time i post something
it can turn into the wrong thing or once
once you post it you you it's there
forever
so then he was like well here let me let
me
you know help you so i started social
media and i was like man it could be a
positive game changer
and change so many people's life you
know so i started and i was like okay
now it's so hard for a football player
to become you know very known on social
media
um you guys like obj that is like tom
brady guys like cam newton like these
are like top tier guys who are like
constantly know
and for myself you know i always say the
president that you know because we wear
a helmet
it's hard for us to show our personality
so ever since i've been in the nfl
i've always hit key points cultured
things that are going
on and just show my personality and just
be myself and i think just like you you
know
you started to post stuff that people
started watching like wow like really
they really
like you know to know the personal life
of myself so
um and just to keep that going on and on
it was just something that's like
very good and you expand your brand to
be something not just more just just an
athlete you know you're
a tick-tock you know an influencer you
do youtube stuff you do you post up on
twitter and like snapchat
it's just it's really cool it's really
cool platform to use in a positive way
yeah have you inspired so you kind of on
your own
or did you see obj posting on like his
instagram and stuff and you're like oh
that's cool or was it something you're
like you know what maybe i'll give this
a try and or you just were enjoying
other people's content and you're like
yeah i can make stuff like that
so it was a little bit of both i think
more so is that
i had so much content that i wouldn't
put out like i would make funny videos
and like we didn't even post it just
like show my friends and i'm getting a
group chat and you'll laugh and i was
like yo you should post that
and i was like oh okay we'll see so then
i just
decided to just start posting like funny
videos you know doing stuff on youtube
uh you know at my at my school and just
like you like you say you know
you see people start liking it you're
like wow okay my
self-confidence there so let me just
keep posting more and more and then uh
it got to the point where
um now i'm like it's a like a star
i guess on social media but like i said
it's just a great platform
to make people feel good i guess for
sure
and it like provides longevity as well
into a different
like branch of your own career so you
have football
you're amazing you're a superstar in
that and then
you have social media as well and like
you said that's your personal life and
people
are able to connect with you even more
and interested in your personal life
even more which opens so many different
avenues of different things you can do
like um i i love watching your content
for me it's
it's so authentic like you can watch
your videos and
you you automatically do feel really
good just even watching you dance
just on the field and stuff like the
energy that you have i'm just like this
guy is awesome
like i want to be his friend and it's so
funny you say that so like
uh we lost our first game yesterday
right and you know i think we i think i
think we needed that you know i didn't
think we needed to be humble
and i'm so happy that it happened early
in our season late but rather late in
the playoffs
so uh and you you know you know when you
like you're very big on social media
when people so i run this one play boom
i get hit i hurt my shoulder okay i get
off i walk off the field because i'm
hurting
and you can hear the other team talking
about go make that tick tock now go
dance now
and let's just in my head i was like is
that what you're really thinking about
right now because like we're playing an
action nfl game
yeah like people think about me doing
two time dances on logos and stuff like
that
and it's just like now you know like
you're more than just bigger than just
being a football player you know
you're doing dance on tick tock you're
doing stuff on on instagram you're doing
stuff on social media where people are
like
you know pointing it out so um it's so
funny that you know people talk about
that
i love it i think it's so cool and keep
doing it
because that's like the content i cannot
and it shows oh my god
this says a lot because even for me like
i'm
i was busy filming all day yesterday all
they did all day the day before
and it's like i i don't even have cable
and i barely have all these platforms
downloaded on my on my phone so i
usually watch highlights or clips or
you know something that i can consume or
if i have time to relax just sit down
and watch a game too
but for me the stuff that i consume
really quickly throughout the day is
stuff on tick tock stuff on instagram
and you're reaching a whole new audience
even if it's not
people that watch football like you're
reaching like a whole different
demographic for yourself
also you know i'm sure a ton of them
watch football but also a ton of them
you're getting exposure to all different
countries as well
which is really cool i don't know for
sure i i'm i'm so curious like how do
you have time
to make content on top of what you're
doing
you know constantly every day uh and i
i i i you know for me like you're
looking at your platform like you're
you're you're playing
obviously 20 times more huge and it's
just like
now you're a person from you know
pittsburgh and
you know it's monroeville which is this
is a cool cool city i like the rivers
to being in l.a now like how for you
it's like you have this huge bathroom
like how do you constantly
keep up with like doing stuff like that
every day while filming
uh just keep going
i don't know like for me i i like what i
do
i think you love what you do too so
that's kind of what fuels me i mean i
can be exhausted but still
show up for things and perform and
feel good about it because i'm happy to
be doing what i do
you know and i feel lucky for it too
like
i feel like a lot of success is
obviously hard work
and there's a lot that needs to go
behind that continuously
to stay at the top or just stay like
climbing and growing towards your new
goals because
i know for me i'm always setting new
goals and for
you i'm sure too especially in sports
you're setting new goals for yourself
too
milestones so that really helps push me
what are some of like the goals you have
set for yourself
this year are going into 2021
yeah so my goals my goals as far as like
football goes you know we talk about a
thousand yards took about 100 catches 10
plus touchdowns
um as a team goal obviously you want to
win a world championship you know like
that's mainly the goal you know i think
um at the end of the day like
me winning the super bowl championship
will override any of my personal goals
when it comes to football
um lifeboat my life goals um that i live
by
daily are literally two things
you know it's two things simple and you
can tell anybody this
one is it's lit
you know always saying it's lit like
every everything i do is
and then two um is
make it make a change in someone's life
in once a day like do something positive
once a day
whether it is telling a random stranger
hi how are you doing today thank you
you know like you know just doing polite
things it doesn't have to be nothing
we're like go out of your way and
buy tv for people or give back to the
community
um it honestly give you as simple as
call your mom
hey mom how are you doing today how's
life what's your how are you doing
anything that's going on like that
um but yeah number two is it's like have
fun
always because when you're having you
have fun doing it it means
it makes everything easy for me school
wasn't the best but i had fun with it
i got through it uh and obviously number
one like i said make a positive make it
change somebody's life
you know once a day i i think
another way to put that too is just like
enjoying the process like a lot of us
um get lost in the day-to-day work of
things
and then we become like robots and then
it's just like you're not
enjoying the process anymore and it's
just not performing as well because that
translates through your work so i think
you're
set up for a ton of success with that
mindset of
keeping it lit and then also
also um paying it forward yeah being
positive making people feel good that
comes back
i believe in karma so much like i just
it comes back to you in so many ways and
not even having that mindset of why
you're doing it it just like feels good
too
to be a good human to other people like
seeing somebody smile is like the
sweetest thing and
they say you you know a lot about a
person um
you know if they have a dog
i know you have bougie
so cute and he's super famous too how do
you do you run his
instagram page he's like yeah yeah
then yeah yeah i run his account and
it's so funny so cute and like with dogs
they're so simple like
you know the best thing about a dog you
know i got bougie coming into my rookie
year and i was like in pittsburgh by
myself all alone at 20 years old
and i didn't have family here so i was
like man we get a dog i got a french
bullet dog because i've always wanted
one you know they're small they don't
shed
you know they're cute they snore and
they're funny their personality so when
i got him
i was like i'm gonna make an instagram
page and with dogs they're so simple oh
you just take a picture of them they're
always cute regardless that they're
doing our videos no photoshop
no no and then when you come home and
you have
a long day at work and you're just like
not feeling it you honestly they are
like
happy just to see you no matter what so
it's cute and boujee
uh he he's definitely a dog he actually
gets
uh he actually get brand deals and some
of that too so it's pretty cool yeah he
did your
um recent what was that the pack
he was on that with you yes he did the
pack on amazon
yeah yeah yeah cool so i love it
he's a superstar yeah it's pretty close
and then also i give his cut you know
you know we split the cut you know
making sure everyone gets paid out
what did he get uh out of the cup
he always said he got 25 000. oh
okay boogie
has he did you train him yourself or is
he trained has
or did you send them off to training
person so i had a trainer
um that would come to my house and we'll
work out we do sessions
um since he was like one years old and
we would just work on stuff and he's
pretty well trained
um i would say i would bring him on
camera but he's with this girlfriend
right now
at her house
oh my god well
rumor has it that there's a lot of fun
to be had especially in the way of
pranks i know you talked about keeping
it lit
but in the locker room what are some of
the best pranks you've played
or that somebody has played on you
the best pranks um man so
it's so funny so um our starting running
by james connor like would take his car
keys and like hide him so he doesn't go
oh no and literally he has to find a
ride home and
when he finds it right when he gets home
he doesn't obviously he doesn't have his
car with him
someone has to bring him back because
then like we'll text they'll text the
equipment guys like yo james connor keys
are actually in his shoes
in his locker so then he has to go all
the way back and that's like one of the
most funniest ones
um guys
you guys go all the way through with it
like you can go
away yes oh yeah imagine like imagine
like
going home 30 minutes and then trying to
find a way back and then
driving back i'd be so annoyed um
another yeah another and then another
funny one is uh
if a rookie messes up or something like
that they'll take all his clothes and
like they put it in a coattail
and he has the word to practice oh my
god
it's not it's brutal in there
yeah it gets pretty tough and other than
that i mean that's
that's pretty much it besides like
nothing like
nothing very little i guess i would say
you know but yeah
let's go home i guess
i mean i i've played some pranks
actually
i think you know him uh andrew batchelor
king batch
yeah so he's he's like my best friend so
we um
especially during like mine days we
would always play pranks
back and forth on each other and
it was like so much fun when you were
playing the prank on
somebody but when they're doing it to
you it's like the worst worst thing
ever and it got like bad
it got to the point where uh what
happened
oh batch leaked my address and then i
leaked his phone number and then he put
confetti all in my car
and it's still to this day and my air
conditioning vents in my car
because he didn't do like just the small
pieces he put big ones down in the
airplanes
yeah and then he like taped up my car
and then i hid
pot pies all around his apartment like
cooked pot pies that smell
horrible if you leave him for like more
than two days so i put him in his closet
like all over his house and it's just
like a stink bomb and he had no idea for
the longest time of where it was coming
from
well that's you guys are going super
intense yeah it's dangerous like and
then we're like okay we need to stop
this is getting tiring how long has this
been going on for
how long was it going out for it was
going on for a good like six months
back and forth so that's so
funny it's a lot the link number and
address is like whoa
that's where it ended that's where it
ended that's when we were like yeah that
was
too much yeah we're done here but a good
thing was that i was moving soon
so there's that and
i knew like i was just i just like
december so
just to get even i'm like you can get a
new one
okay it's my life yeah
but i i do want to know because i mean
you play so many different teams
is there always a favorite team that you
like to play
um certain stadiums i do like playing in
um just because the environment's loud
and tough um
so i like uh cleveland
rounds they're awesome statement plan
just because everything's close
holders and it's tight um it's very loud
um their fans are
insanely crazy so i love to go over
there and win
um i also love playing in mercedes dome
which is the saints stadium which is
super loud
obviously too um and then i also love
playing at home
and you think about what still donation
fans they're literally
everywhere we play against the los
angeles chargers last year
and honestly i might i can tell you like
it was probably like eighty percent
it felt like a home it was literally a
home game for us oh god
that's awesome yeah and it's so
cool so i mean you're probably busy now
but if you go to the super bowl i'll
promise you i'll give you two tickets
oh my god i am there count i'm there
bring your boyfriend and find the
babysitter from falco and then
definitely set it up so much fun and
i'm pretty sure wherever we go it's like
still the fans are insane but honestly
the best game to play in is probably
pittsburgh
yeah oh man i don't know if you've ever
been to a game in pittsburgh but it's
it's
crazy yes yeah it's it was freezing
but it was so much crazy that's probably
one thing you do not miss about
pittsburgh it is
so cold here it's like literally like
but it's
it's it's better now you know but the
snow is insane
yeah that's why i would think you would
just like list all the warmest cities to
play in
or warm estates you're just like yeah
this is what i prefer
because do you perform better in warmer
weather or
yeah yeah obviously i think you do um
but i think it's also pretty cool that
like you know because we're the code
we love to have teams that are like from
the west coast who play in warm weather
they come to the co and they're like oh
yeah
out here that's true well i remember one
game after my
rookie year we played against uh the
browns and it was probably like five
degrees
i kid you not and like when it gets that
code um we use this thing called skin
warmth it's like this this like little
like cream
you rub on your body you mix it with
vaseline you put it in your nose so you
can breathe rather and then like
literally just covers all your pores
so by the time you sweat and like you're
running like you feel totally good you
feel warm
oh whoa is that sold to the public yeah
yeah i'm gonna get some of that next
time i go to like
colorado or pittsburgh when i go to
where's the super bowl this year
it's gonna it's gonna be in for us in
tampa oh okay
so i should not apply my skin warmth
before
that yeah when you when you guys play
because you're making it there
you're getting the damn ring that is
happening that energy
out there the same way we trust
essential workers to provide the care
they give to us our families trust us to
give them a safe
and protected home today's episode is
brought to you by clorox one accounts
trust clorox
our community here is trust clorox to
keep places like hospitals grocery
stores
disinfected so i know i too can trust
clorox to provide my home with a safe
environment at home we can all enjoy
that is why i trust clorox regular
bleach by mixing 1 3 cup of clorox
regular
bleach with one gallon of water when
used as directed on
hard non-porous surfaces it kills 99.9
of germs and bacteria on a variety of
surfaces
from our kitchen floors to counters to
bathroom tabs to of course
laundry wipes i know i can count on
clorox disinfecting products to give
myself and my family the best home we
deserve
i use clorox disinfecting products at my
home to keep my floors clean
my door handles clean and just
everything clean because i got a little
puppy running around
for me it's important to share with
loved ones and the public in general how
they can give the most care for their
loved ones because
when it counts trespass
you believe in a manifestation
do i believe just like when you
say something this is gonna happen you
put that energy out there and you kind
of manifest it for yourself
of just like you know what this is going
to be a good day everything's going to
be good and it turns out to be a great
day because you put that energy out
there
oh yes yes or writing things down
yes yes all of that so for me it's like
um
kind of i don't think the same thing
like if i dream however how we're going
to play like the game's going to go
i drew me back the night before i wake
up the next day and i like okay this is
this is how the vibes are and this is
what i think so yes i believe that
yeah and that's something i've i don't
know i i just feel like
maybe it changes your perspective a
little bit too but the more
i'm like confident in something or
putting that like positive vibes out
there that you
radiate all the time it really just
makes a huge difference
so any how do you deal with like and i
know this is
such a common question i mean anytime i
do interviews
i always get asked this and i have like
a copy and paste answer at this point
but
maybe you have something new for me but
when
when it comes to like the hate comments
and everything you know i'm sure
you receive like other fans from other
teams and
like your comment section or yeah
yeah definitely it's so funny so tonight
i have a stream
um on twitch and i have to like and we
just lost on me all that tonight so
um but with the hate the hate comment
it's marshall like for me it's just like
you know not everyone's gonna wish you
the best you know like you're gonna have
haters out there like that's gonna be a
comment
everything you do you know especially
you know in the sports industry
um people it's very competitive so for
me it's more so like
make the best out of it you know you
take those hate you take those negative
vibes and you turn it into positive
like it's there's no point to be
down on yourself because you have people
hate on you and others negative vibes
and you're not feeling that
for me it's just more so like hey i'll
take those i'll take those words and
i'll
you know use it for motivation and i'll
become better um at the end of the day
you know it's life it moves on things
happens for a reason
you learn from your mistakes you learn
from you know what you've lost and
you gain from it and you come back 20
times stronger
and to make them stop hating you
honestly just
do you and i guess at that day i'm not
doing even in your position like
you're gonna have haters because
they don't want to see you shine and
you're going to get those
messages and you probably get those
messages now and you probably get
you know those those people in the
comments talking you know trash and
that's just them
but you know everyone's going to have
haters and that's just the way life is
you know what i tried doing um was like
eminem in it
uh and just like call it like even
i even did it during this podcast like
calling out um
i'm bandwagon before the comments even
got to it
it's like ha i beat you to it but it's
it's funny because it's like
obviously some comments are just like
brutal and just
not even and there's zero truth to it
and then some comments you're just like
well yeah okay
take a note and you can apply it yeah
because it's some some can be
constructive but most of the hate
comments are just
hate and like like you said it's just
like all right how can i
i'm gonna flip you over to the other
side one day but it's fine it's like
it's not if anything that's fuel for me
to
do more in life so thanks for feeding me
you know
oh no for sure and that's and that's
that's a really cool thing you know
like the way you think about it the way
you know i think that's awesome
um but thanks you know just
trying to be like youtube just do you
i'm trying to be like juju
just do you and you talking like me but
i'm really sorry
we are each other can i actually a
question
uh-huh one la question what is your
favorite place to eat at
in l.a oh um
okay so i'm vegan
so yeah that's fine okay what is your
favorite vegan spot
yeah so
oh okay cool so mine is crossroads
oh you have to go to crossroads it's um
it's on melrose i believe
and sweet sir
okay okay yeah
at the crossroads but it's it's really
good it's like a fine dining
vegan cuisine it's like it's very loungy
a cool vibe it's not like
overly plants and stuff in your face
yeah
yeah yeah kind of like a cheap vegan
yeah i mean i tried vegan food and it's
like respect to you
i don't know how long you've been vegan
for but 11 years
11 years yeah is your boyfriend vegan
so wait what's your favorite um vegan
place
veggie grill oh girl you consider that
vegan that's vegan right
oh yeah full on yeah like yeah so with
veggie grill the reason i love it
because
like it's normal food it looks like
normal food you know like the burgers
even though it's like obviously
plant-based and like
but it just looks everything's natural
and it tastes
so good and it's just so healthy and
that's my favorite it's crazy what they
can do
and what they can make out of plants
like you look at it you're like all
right this is a little bit more
processed but it's better than the
alternative
and then i i know you're you would love
if you like veggie girl
you're gonna love crossroads and you're
gonna remember and thank me forever that
you go there
so i'll definitely try it yeah you have
to
uh it's so much fun because it's just
such a vibe like veggie girl is cool to
like order from i feel like
yes i was just like order from there but
like actually going and
sitting down and eating um crossroads is
cool but i feel like
there's so many restaurants in la that
have vegan options like
literally every restaurant here has a
vegan menu so
what is your favorite non-vegan
restaurant in l.a
uh so i'm a sucker for korean bbq
oh yeah that's the only one that does
not have vegan options
yeah i take it back but as far as like
for food like overall great meal i'm
probably gonna go with the
mastros i love mashups i love their
butter cake
is insane is it still open
i don't know i've not been to la the
past three four months i don't know how
it is right now and everything no so
three four months you were here and
it was open yeah yeah last month yeah
like last year or just earlier this year
did they change locations or something i
i felt like there's
one yeah so there's one in beverly hills
that
yeah that i would go to um there's also
one like i think it's malibu
by nobu but other than that like that's
uh
i just love nationals like you're
staying stuff honestly the butter cake
is just like
i missed this lot to say i don't know i
don't know how you feel about permanent
brothers which is from pittsburgh
what is you ever heard of manny brothers
no
okay so it's like it's big thing in
pittsburgh and it's like honestly i'm
not trying to down pittsburgh but it's
probably not the best
and pittsburgh is all right i'm coming
from l.a everything in la is just
it's so good i agree i mean like even
coming from florida here it's like
because i spend a lot of time in florida
so yeah when i'm here i'm like oh
so many more options and the flavors and
everything's just so good
but um yeah la definitely does have a
one-up on other
other states i think when it comes to
food but i i will say you said a lot of
motivation
for you is numbers right numbers are a
big thing
in life and that comes with like um
different like goals that you set for
yourself within the game different
financial goals that you set for
yourself just to be able to live the
lifestyle
that you want and give boujee his
lifestyle too
and so with that you even started your
own
merch line like which includes hoodies
hats
masks with your brand all over it
and you're selling it now for the
holidays too right
are there any discounts or hookups
you're doing for the holidays for your
fan base
on and it's team gpu.com right where
they can find yes yes yes
tng.com um so yes obviously we have
stuff on sales
obviously for all the merch um
especially
um you know with with the whole bougie
the new team juju line and everything
it's pretty cool
um literally the first we dropped i
think like couple days
or i think a week ago like in the
morning and we sold out literally in
seconds
and it was like it was tough because um
stiller fans like they we don't have a
lot of people on our team that this
merch
that's very like out there like that so
when i drop you like
out so like now for christmas we're
trying to get all that back up going
like
you know and now i'm pretty sure you get
the same thing in your comments and
everything about merch and about stuff
like
hey where are you when are you dropping
this game when you're dropping this
again can you click do you guys ship to
you know outside the country and it's
just like i constantly
get those uh comments like messages and
that's just something that's like
very popular so and it's pretty simple
you know it's nothing too crazy
something you can order you know on a
daily and out so
um definitely guys send me some gear
amanda so yeah no i'll order it i'll go
on
i mean you might have to send it if it's
all sold out like but
i'll try to order it but i think that's
so awesome and i love how
entrepreneurial you are
and i'm sure you're building other
things like is there anything that you
can talk about business
wise of things that you're working on
yeah so um
right now i just i've started a gaming
team called team diverge
uh it's a gaming company i love love
video games
um since i was a kid so that's always
been a deer in their passion
to my heart um so we pretty much what's
your what's your favorite game
right now fortnight um it's fortnite
it's what's going on nowadays fortnite
in my call of duty
nice does uh did your
wait what does he play on a pc
oh oh you're in his gaming setup yeah
yeah that's awesome
definitely cool um but yeah now a bit
big gamer
and then like i said you know i started
team diverse because i've always been a
big gamer and i want to be able to
compete
and this is something that's like near
and dear to my heart so if i'm going to
do something
100 for passion so why not gaming
i love it and how do you recruit for
your team
um so we just did a recruitment on an rc
basically
and we pretty much put on social media
people sit in their clips it's they tag
us
and then we have interviews with certain
players like that
so and b go compete you make money and
you know there's a lot of young kids a
lot of young gamers who are just hungry
and you can see them now that people are
making a living off this so
it's really cool to see uh these young
kids do it
i saw how much uh johannes has improved
over quarantine too
and i'm just like all right like these
gamers out here are probably just like
really just like skill levels going up
up up
up with all like the time and people
willing to play and just oh my god it's
such a community it's so cool
yeah it's awesome because like um the
fact that you uh
uh he can play on pc that's like
hi nexo you know because like if he's a
real live gamer he's on pc he's a real
live gamer
and that's really cool yeah i know i i
was trying
to set up one in florida too and
for me i'm like this is complicated for
anybody who wants to set up a pc
like i'm like knowing exactly what to
get and all that
like i'm sure there's some vlogs out
there and stuff that would have made it
easier but
i'm like you have to really put this
together
it's a whole it's a whole thing it's not
easy
definitely easy yeah well i love that
and i do want to ask you one more
question before we go to uh
feels good fan questions really quick
that some people wrote in for you
um but just now especially i'm sure the
energy is so much different when you're
playing games
with empty stadiums or you know
especially
with coverage restrictions so how how
does that affect
everybody's playtime are you because
you're not able to hype yourself off off
the energy of like
you know the fans around you so
obviously we're not allowed to have fans
we don't have fans in our stadium and
obviously you want to feel the energy
uh between your fans so right now with
kobe everything we're only like family
members so in the stance
all you see is like hey well hey dad in
like 80
in like the 68 000 likes stadium is like
mom dad
brother sister and then like you have
like people's like girlfriend
family members so there's only like 60
people in the stands cheering you on
right can you please shoot a video like
that
yes i'll definitely shoot i'll show you
our next home video for you this is
our next home game will be after
christmas so i'll be able to show you
that'll be so just edit it
like have it just a full-on like sketch
i think that'd
be hilarious just to see that mom
it's just empty and small empty
so and then also with kobe we get tested
every day so we get to know swap
every day um in the morning and then if
you get kobe obviously you're out for 10
days um
and we also wear trackers for people out
there who are wondering where these
trackers the little device
um because if you're a person who i
covered if you test positive and you
within seven minutes of him
you can be opt out for five days too
whoa
that detailed wow yes that's so cool
literally
literally and also um
we have the most craziest like we played
three games
in 12 days because of kobe because the
game's being pushed back
like we played last wednesday we play
this monday we play next sunday
so it's like with cope and everything in
football season everything is
cluttered together and it just messes
everything up and just takes a toll on
my body
for sure i mean i get when you're sore
from a workout you need like recovery
days and if you're
playing a hundred percent on the field
like oh my god
you need a massage you need a spa day
you need
hey after the super bowl you can just
like fully
see i'm putting i'm putting that energy
out there it's happening i swear
yeah you already know so we'll go to fan
questions really quickly so i'm going to
just riddle these off
what does juju mean and when did it
become what everyone called you uh yeah
so juju is just a media episode nickname
um i was saying like four or five years
old my auntie made me like choo choo
train
and then ever since then it's been like
juju
so like people don't even know my real
name unless i say like no no me
so for example like in middle school
high school
teachers parents other people who say
and then like when it comes down to like
me writing my name like to sign
i always said to sign my real name so
i'll put like john smith schuster
and i added shuster
as my second last name because of my
stepfather so at first i used to beat
john smith
so my you ever see like the example
names like s.a.t people like john smith
it's so funny so yeah juju is a nickname
so yeah
i love it that's such a good story and
so freaking cute
choo choo does anybody call you choo
choo still
no no we're not starting that we're not
no we're not doing that
all right even though we really want to
all right next question do you prefer
the gym atmosphere
or working outside
um that's tough
i honestly prefer the working outside
i'm the type person to
to be outside outdoors whether it's
stairs whether it's doing
you know stuff on the football field uh
being able to um
you know mainly run routes catch the
vlog stuff like that how about you
i i think i don't know i think i'd like
i like outside but body weight exercises
outside see it's like i'm not
i'm not lifting huge weights in the gym
like i'm all about like
just doing body weight workouts a lot of
hit training so
i like being in different locations for
that and i think it's more
entertaining than just being in like a
closed gym
but yeah i feel like i'm multitasking
too
all right so who is the best
cornerback you've ever played against um
i would have to say
uh stephon gilmore um he's a cornerback
for the patriots he's really good
um i respect his game and he's he's one
of those guys that you know he's a he's
a
veteran guy um that's playing for a very
long time so
i give him the respect and say it's him
all right this question
do you want to retire as a steeler or
would you like the chance to play for
other teams as well
like politics i know right
yeah this is like one of those questions
where like you have to you know
don't be too honest but let them know
like hey yeah of course i'm tired
you're a businessman too yeah of course
man this is a business game
i would definitely love to retire
distillers um
obviously you know with the whole
contract and everything going on this
year
for me so um distillers have to sign me
before
um march 15th
and if they don't then i'm gonna hit the
market and see what other teams have to
offer
that could be a good tick tock tick tock
time is ticking
for decisions all right final question
um oh actually no there's like two more
okay
who do you think is going to play in the
super bowl we already know this the
steelers are going to be in the super
bowl this year and if you had to lay
bets
what team will win steelers all right go
ahead you can answer it
i think i might answer for me already
okay perfect
moving on do you know who stole your
bike
uh yeah so um fun
fun fact fun story so i didn't have my
license i was 20 years old coming to
pittsburgh so
i lived by the facility obviously in
southside and i
bought a bike and every day i was riding
my bike to work
and one morning i was late to meetings
because my bike was stolen
so it went viral hit the social media
and like became like this biggest thing
that pittsburgh that people just love to
talk about
and i offered the so one of my teammates
offered the guy
free tickets and 200 if he would change
the bike
and then the person that returned the
bike we found out that he had like 100
bikes stolen in his house
and yeah and this is like
mount oliver so this is like next to
mount washington
um in pittsburgh and literally
this guy tried to collect the two
tickets and the 200
but instead he ends up like
getting caught and having all these
bikes in his house so then that's like
been like the biggest thing
um i work here for bikes and then after
that
we did i did like this um you did a sink
operation
yeah you did it that's legit
then after that like a bike has been a
huge thing for me so like after that i
received like five more bikes from like
five different companies because they
just they saw how big it was
and then i ended up giving like a 100
bikes away and i ended up giving
100 bikes to boys and girls club and
then we also gave
20 bikes away for each state um
so did we get away a lot of bikes
honestly
practice what you preach my friend give
him back
but also talking about business
opportunities
i would buy a juju bike so
a little choo choo bike is what juju
i would get you should make your own
bikes that's what i'm saying
like that's a whole like who has their
own bike brand you do
so that'd be cool and then you could do
that every year and give back every year
with your own brand
i mean most definitely please do that
also
i'm taking your idea no it's yours
i just like reiterated it so i think
this is all great i don't want to take
any more
of your free day your you time your juju
time
so thank you so much for being here
thanks so much for hanging out and
talking with me
i have your number we're going to be
friends forever because
our astrology makes sense and
i love you and i am going to be your
friend
forever so i'm just making that clear so
thank you i appreciate it honestly
everybody thanks for having me i
appreciate all
those great questions uh sorry that
jackman was here but
i said hi and then also um thank you
amanda you're awesome
and it feels good to be on feels good so
it's awesome it's great
well thank you again and i'll i'll talk
to you later have
great games coming forward take care of
yourself take care of your health
and you're gonna kill it and i'll see
you at the super bowl i'll see you there
see ya